[Musique]
madame d'une voiture déjà injecté je
pose quelques mois déjà puis bal avant
un an je crois que personne ne donne
c'est une chaude soirée d'été sur
l'autoroute 20 à la hauteur de
saint-apollinaire près québec il est 21
heures 20
la scène et mystérieuse plusieurs
s'arrête pour signaler l'accident des
appels jamais diffusés jusqu'à
maintenant
ambulanciers policiers et pompiers sont
dépêchés sur les lieux
ce soir-là au kilomètre 288 la vie de
martin carpentier bascule et celle de
tous ses proches aussi ils se sauvent
des lieux de l'accident avec ses deux
filles avant de les tuer et de s'enlever
la vie
les corps de nora et remy sont retrouvés
trois jours après l'accident
[Musique]
et ça prend neuf jours de plus pour
trouver celui de leur père
c'est la fin d'une vaste opération
policière pour la sûreté du québec une
des plus marquantes de son histoire et
qui presque deux ans plus tard soulève
encore beaucoup de questions
[Musique]
je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui on a la
certitude que tout ce qui pouvait être
fait aux idées mais notre enquête
démontre que tout ce qu'ils auraient dû
être faits n'a pas été fait selon des
policiers qui ont participé à cette
opération
la sûreté du québec a commis des erreurs
qui n'ont jamais été dévoilées
nora romy et martin carpentier aurait
possiblement pu être retrouvé avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
[Musique]
novembre 2021 ça fait presque un an et
demi qu amélie lemieux a perdu ses
filles
dans la douleur des papillons sur les
arbres nous mène jusqu'à elle mais là on
arrive à nora
berra nora est ici puis remis et là bas
amélie lemieux a planté deux arbustes
aux endroits où nora et remy ont été
retrouvés à une cinquantaine de mètres
l'une de l'autre
j'aimerais que mes amis ouais je n'ai
que les amis en henrard est ce que tu
vois ça comme un lieu de recueillement
gb oui oui beaucoup passer les derniers
moments les derniers souffles
nora est excité ici sont ceux des
emprunts faire moi on me l a traîné
dubois influent préparation et un abri
en construction certains éléments
laisser croire que les filles
s'apprêtaient à passer une deuxième nuit
dans le bois avec leur père
une scène qui a marqué la fin de la
carrière de cet ancien policier
spécialisé en recherches andré bernard
est maintenant retraité et les animaux
de sa ferme est le tiennent bien occupé
c'est lui qui a fait la triste
découverte avec son équipe le samedi 11
juillet sur l'heure du dîner et c'est la
première fois qu'il en parle
publiquement
moi personnellement je manque avec 4
lorsqu'ils trouvent les cadavres des
enfants andré bernard en est à sa
troisième journée à saint-apollinaire il
est arrivé sur les lieux le lendemain
matin de l'accident ce jeudi matin on
sait que
ce véhicule qui prit un embardée puis
que la personne qui bouge et on s'en va
là bas on a proposé un freak show andré
bernard et ses collègues sont basés à
mascouche deux heures et demie de route
les séparent de cette apollinaire ils
arrivent sur place vers 9h30
ornithology bureau autrement dit roy on
était 2 3 causées vacances ce n'est pas
suffisant pour faire des recherches des
patrouilleurs d'autoroutes sont appelés
pour pallier le manque d'effectifs mais
c'est encore plus on arrive à former
seulement deux équipes de recherche ont
offert avec ce condo les gens chrono les
fouilles commence au nord de l'autoroute
on n'a rien trouvé votre trace produits
d'hygiène
c'est au sud de l'autoroute plus tard en
après midi qu andré bernard trouve un
premier indice j'avais une trace de
sandales mis à une trace de pied
vraiment nu pire bonne et rapide hors
vraiment on faut pour faire une plus
belle trace ction envahissent une
sandale de nora avait justement été
abandonné dans la voiture il emprunte
trouvé par andré bernard correspond à
cette sandale à ce moment à l'aube alors
ça nous ça ne nous confirmer que des
filles avec carpentier net passer l'or
du rhin à quel moment durant nuit jeu se
pose c'est une découverte majeure qui
mènent rapidement les policiers à une
autre empreinte environ 800 mètres plus
loin celle de romy je perds c'est que le
maître chien et de chat
le poignet d'odeurs puis on a perdu la
trace dans le rap pire en était rendu
tort pour ne pas de remplaçant ça finit
là vont ni jeudi a sans droit l'eau à
l'endroit où la deuxième trace a été
trouvé il est environ 20h quand les
recherches sont suspendues sur le
terrain pour la nuit ça va faire 24
heures que les petites et leur père
manquent à l'appel est ce que vous étiez
surpris qu'on arrête les recherches
baisse parce qu'il marque edmond on
n'était pas à sa demande sa plus grande
surprise ça a été le lendemain matin moi
je matin que le lendemain matin or
comment cela
mais la sûreté du québec déplace son
poste de commandement et toutes ses
équipes beaucoup plus loin dans un petit
quartier résidentiel situé à environ 7
km de la dernière trace trouvé la veille
on y vendredi ça fait trente six heures
que martin carpentier ses filles sont
disparus
je comprenais pas je comprenais tout
simplement pour qu'on ne pas
d'affairisme on devrait connaître un
dernier point connu à partir de là puis
arrête pas de relancer au technicien lui
comprend vie il fait bon passer pour lui
qui décide c'est qui qui décident
dissocier qui a deux filles recevront
les clients qui auraient été entendues
dans ce secteur au cours de la nuit
information considérée comme étant très
important ils sont amenés à nous
déplacer si dans le secteur c'est la
dernière des stratégies à faire des on
démantèle ici et on tourne plus loin sur
un autre information
[Musique]
alain croteau s'y connaît en matière de
disparition et la gérer de nombreuses
opérations de recherches au cours de sa
carrière à la sûreté du québec jusqu'à
sa retraite il ya un an c'est lui qui
formaient ses collègues policiers il est
catégorique c'est une erreur de déplacer
les recherches à plusieurs kilomètres
d'un dernier indice comme une trace de
pas même si des citoyens disent avoir
entendu des cris qu'on envoie une équipe
b l'idée qu'on a envoyé maître chien
patane valider oui ok mais jamais jamais
jamais jamais qu'on déplace l'ensemble
des recherches pour aller lot jamais
surtout que dans ce cas ci la découverte
d'une trace de pas dans le premier rayon
de 300 mètres autour du lieu de
l'accident est un élément clé pour la
suite de l'opération
cette trace de polo est là les verts où
ça veut d'abord dire que le père et ses
deux filles se déplacent vers le sud
l'autre information précieuse c'est une
logone et l'autre pieds nus ce que ça
vienne nous dire c'est que les
probabilités qu'est la personne soit en
train de marcher en pleine forêt sont à
peu près nulles donc on emprunte fabrice
clément les chemins voici vous avez déjà
marcher pieds nus en forêt non c'est ça
fonctionne pas bien on n'avance pas puis
après ça on est avec deux jeunes enfants
le vendredi après une deuxième journée
de recherches infructueuses
la sûreté du québec suspend à nouveau
les recherches pour la nuit nora et romy
sont disparus depuis 48 heures
le samedi une troisième journée de
recherches commencent avec le
débarquement de nombreux citoyens à
cette apollinaire qui veulent aider on
demande aux pompiers de les encadrer
pour éviter de nuire au travail des
policiers qui eux retournent finalement
aux dernières traces de pas et la suite
donne raison à andré bernard
[Musique]
on a découvert les deux petites filles
qui étaient qui était décédé à son
endroit à l'autre
les corps sont tout près de la dernière
trace de pas à quelques centaines de
mètres
et à seulement deux kilomètres du lieu
de l'accident
face à leur idole mais qu on aurait pu
faire la différence ça devrait provenir
d'un même clairement qu'on a perdu une
journée 1-1 ne suivant pas les règles de
l'art dans le meilleur des mondes c'est
si tout avait bien été n'aurait pu
retrouver vivante peut-être
on
veut toutes les trouver en vie puis on
nous donne pas tout les moyens pour le
faire
[Musique]
comme publique ordinaire on peut avoir
une certaine impression de l'opération
de recherche de la excuse qui n'a pas
permis de retrouver les fillettes
carpentier à temps mais dans un geste
très rare des spécialistes la recherche
qui était à la sûreté du québec à
l'époque vont nous dire que ce qui s'est
passé c'est une série d'erreurs
martin carpentier est décrit comme un
père présent attentionné et dévoué pour
ses filles
ou ce que je dis souvent c'est que mes
filles étaient à la mauvaise place au
mauvais moment avec la personne que les
amis de plus
lorsqu'elle rencontre martin carpentier
en 2008 amélie le mieux est déjà
enceinte
même s'il n'est pas le père biologique
il assiste à l'accouchement et c'est lui
qui est là pour la petite nora dès sa
naissance
rapidement il parle d'adoption
depuis que j'étais enceinte
avec ma fille c'est moi qui ai le sait
moins que sans nos tubes samoa en pige
oui mais si on veut faire les choses
dans les règles de l'art
le couple se marie en 2010 et quelques
mois plus tard martin carpentier devient
officiellement le père de nora
leur deuxième fille romy est né en 2013
deux ans plus tard en 2015 amélie le
muet martin carpentier se séparent c'est
lui qui garde la maison familiale porte
voisine du jumelé de ses ex beaux
parents il a une relation privilégiée
avec eux quand le drame survient en 2020
ça fait cinq ans qu'amélie lemieux
martin carpentier sont séparés tous les
deux sont en couple à nouveau depuis
quelques années
malgré tout martin carpentier entretient
une obsession de perdre ses filles
c'est un homme discret et sans histoires
jusqu'à ce qu'il parte de chez lui avec
nora et remis le 8 juillet 2020 on a
refait le trajet de ce mercredi soir où
tout a basculé
martin carpentier
quand il est parti de chez lui il ne
mangeait un cornet de crème glacée avec
nora est remis si on est le 8 juillet il
faisait vraiment chaud compter dans une
séquence de chaleur la première partie
elle m'a dit qu'ils reviendraient
pour à peu près nova
vingt-et-une par ce qu'avaient dit les
cousins en horreur remis à terre la
maison était chez les grands-parents
juste à côté du coucher là
c'est sur le chemin du retour ou km 288
de l'autoroute 20 que martin carpentier
perd le contrôle de son véhicule il
traverse le terre-plein central pour
terminer sa course en sens inverse et le
père quitte les lieux avec les filles
[Musique]
on
sait maintenant que qui a traversé
toutes les voies de l'autoroute avec les
filles il ya traverser le chemin de fer
ici
pour finalement s'enfoncer dans le bois
du côté sud
mais en long et en juillet donc il ya
des feuilles dans les arbres
c'est beaucoup plus vert il est 21h15 il
fait noir qui est avec deux fillettes il
ya peu son cellulaire
alors que martin carpentier s'enfuit
dans le bois avec ses filles son
véhicule est retrouvé sur l'autoroute 20
à l'intérieur il ya un cellulaire une
sandale une tablette un portefeuille et
de la crème glacée à peine fondu saveurs
barbe à papa
rapidement les patrouilleurs signal
l'accident au centre de surveillance de
la sûreté du québec
les premières informations transmises
impact important air bag déployer
possibilité de trois occupants un adulte
et deux enfants
dès 22h les officines la sûreté du
québec savent que des enfants sont
impliqués dans cette histoire
le cellulaire abandonné dans l'auto a
sonné quelques minutes après la
découverte de la voiture et c'est un
patrouilleur qui a répondu au bout du
fil les grands-parents de nora et romy
ils sont inquiets parce que martin n'a
pas l'habitude d'être en retard caméra
thermique maître chien des recherches
sont effectuées autour du véhicule pour
vérifier si les occupants ont été
éjectés
s'est planté warcoing d'avoir un corps
fait que kaiser youlton se rende ici
pendant ce temps le père et ses deux
filles sont encore tout près il marche
dans le boisé jusqu'à une roulotte qui a
été démoli depuis en toute honnêteté je
pense pas qu'ils ont senti le danger
quelques ports pour en voir leur peur
même si elle le sait déprimé et fatigué
depuis un certain temps amélie lemieux
ne pense pas que martin carpentier
puisse s'en prendre à nora et romy mais
ce n'est pas normal qu'ils ne donnent
pas signe de vie
elle décide de lancer un appel à tous
sur facebook
la nuit passe et c'est seulement le
lendemain matin à 7 heures que la sûreté
du québec fait appel à ces policiers
spécialisés en recherche ils sont
seulement trois et ils partent de
mascouche il arrive à saint-apollinaire
vers 9h30 en avant midi les pompiers
interpellent des automobilistes à
l'entrée de la ville avec les photos des
disparus
mais pendant plusieurs heures la sûreté
du québec demandent aux journalistes de
ne pas diffuser l'information une alerte
amber est déclenchée vers 15 heures la
police recherche un père et ses deux
enfants on déploie tous les moyens pour
tenter de retrouver justement ses deux
fillettes il s'est écoulé 18 heures
depuis l'accident est ce que l'on sait
pourquoi l'alerté amber est déclenchée
suter marie peur je me suis posé la même
question que vous le rapport de la
coroner nous apprendra que c'est
pratiquement à ce moment là alors qu'on
est en ondes et qu'on diffuse l'alertent
ambert que martin carpentier commet
l'irréparable
il ya vraiment sommet les filles est
parti il tue c'est fait d'un violent
coup de branches à la tête avant de
prendre la fuite pieds nus et de
s'enlever la vie cinq kilomètres plus
loin
[Musique]
enfin l'embardée un père de famille deux
enfants se rappelle il y avait de la
crème glacée bon d'autres éléments qui
pourraient nous laisser penser que les
jeunes filles étaient là
l'urgence est là marcel savard a été
policier pendant 38 ans la sûreté du
québec l'ancien directeur général
adjoint s'explique mal qu'on ait autant
tardé à saisir l'urgence de la situation
et a déployé des équipes sur le terrain
selon lui même si la famille dit que
nora et remy ne sont pas en danger avec
leur père les policiers doivent
envisager tous les scénarios sur lequel
tu va tarder le plus celui qui met à
risque les enfants ou celui qui rassure
tout le monde et que finalement il n'y a
pas de près il n'y a pas d'urgence dans
les situations moi je pense la rose la
fonction policière ces boucs plus
d'envisager le pays
il ya plus de dix ans après la
disparition de cédrika provencher un
sous ministre l'avait rappelé à tous les
directeurs de police du québec il leur
avait écrit s'il manque du renseignement
pour identifier correctement le type de
disparition elle doit être traitée comme
le pire des scénarios c'est à dire un
enlèvement avec risque pour la vie ça me
surprend qu'on n'ait pas été aussi
rapide qu'on aurait dû dans ce dossier
dos je le pensais je pense encore que l'
alerte amber auraient dû déclencher
beaucoup plus rapidement sera soit doré
est un ancien policier de la sûreté du
québec on l'a vu régulièrement à
l'époque de la disparition de la petite
cédrika provencher
attention ce type d'information l'eau en
juillet 2020 il a pris la parole dans
les médias concernant l'opération de
cette apollinaire comme il le fait
régulièrement depuis qu'il est retraité
mais cette fois ci la sûreté du québec
n'a pas apprécié j'ai reçu deux appels
téléphoniques de membres de la sûreté du
québec j'ai senti une forme de pression
on voulait peut-être préserver l'image
anzin bagarre depuis ce n'est pas tout
tu connais pas toutes les lignes les
donné l'alerté vers ne pouvait pas
déclencher plus rapidement sauf que bon
ils vivent de la vie de trois personnes
le père et deux enfants
quand les officiers la sûreté du québec
saisissent finalement l'urgence de la
situation il peine à trouver des
policiers pour monter des équipes de
recherche pourtant le service de police
de québec offre rapidement l'aide de ses
propres équipes spécialisées une offre
que refuse alors la sûreté du québec
selon nos sources
historiquement il était connu que les
services de police avaient une tendance
assez forte à garder pour eux leurs
dossiers de moins possible faire affaire
avec des partenaires policiers ou et je
pense que actuellement au québec cette
espèce de relation entre les services de
police est en train d'évoluer beaucoup
mais il ya encore une tendance à dire
non on a les ressources pour le faible
on se perd pas dans un environnement
comme ça on disparaît dans un
environnement de même mais on ne se perd
pas parce qu'il ya des chemins partout
nettement on a affaire à un individu qui
est en crise s'il avait eu à gérer cette
recherche alain croteau aurait sans
doute suggéré la suspension des
recherches le soir tout en s'assurant
qu'une voiture banalisée patrouille les
chemins pendant la nuit une façon de
diminuer la pression sur une personne
potentiellement dépressive comme martin
carpentier
c'est une stratégie ça veut pas dire que
c'est gagné ça donne une soupape ça
donne la possibilité de sortir puis deux
on efface tout et on recommence
martin a été
contrarié y quelque chose il ya de quoi
qui s'est passé mais moins apprécié
panique et ses sursauts et alec
retournerai probablement pas recommander
l'utilisation d'hélicoptères
c'est de le pousser dans un entonnoir
dans lesquels il veut pas vendre et non
seulement ça risque de les stresser mais
l'hélicoptère est inefficace lorsqu'on a
affaire à quelqu'un qui se cache quant à
la caméra thermique comme celle de
l'avion de transport canada c'est 5% de
taux d'efficacité arrêtons la poudre aux
yeux parce que la podologie ça marche
pas ça fonctionne à 100 à calmer les
esprits ça fonctionne dans ce sens dont
on va le trouver
je trouve que c'est un chemin qui est
très dangereux pour la sûreté du québec
de de tomber dans leur on a l'air de
faire quelque chose
on en a l'air de faire quelque chose
ça donne des frissons dans le dos
son expérience lui laisse croire que
martin carpentier n'est pas parti de
chez lui avec l'intention de tuer ses
filles à mon avis c'est une chaîne
d'éléments qui fait en sorte que à un
moment donné à la meinau l'engrenage et
puis l'eau c'est go en avant son sol on
va aller réfléchir un peu au les
hélicoptères légers ou est-ce que je
suis rendu
j'allais trop loin j'ai pu jouer
[Musique]
c'est lui qui m'a enlevé mes filles mais
si c'est autant une victime parce qu'ils
avaient besoin days celle ci comprend
dans quel état d'esprit y était c'est ma
grosse question c'est avec la question
de ma vie pourquoi qui était jusque là
dans son état d'esprit commun qui a fait
[Musique]
ce qui est troublant dans le drame de
cette apollinaire c'est que quelques
mois auparavant
là est ce qu est la ministre avait été
prévenue que les unités de recherche
étaient désorganisés et que ça pourrait
avoir des conséquences tragiques et
c'est ce qui est arrivé
[Musique]
on les appelle quand une catastrophe
survient ou que la tension monte les
policiers des unités d'urgence de la
sûreté du québec sont formés entraînés
et équipés ils sont spécialisés en
recherche terrestre ils doivent être
prêts à se déployer rapidement n'importe
où dans la province les effectifs sont
répartis dans trois points de service
mascouche saint-hubert et québec
[Musique]
recherchait quelqu'un en forêt c'est
c'est un job très spécial et il ya des
gens qui trouvent pas le dans le
frigidaire
alain croteau est considéré par
plusieurs comme une sommité en
recherches terrestres au québec
lorsqu'il a été honoré en 2009 par le
ministère de la sécurité publique on l'a
présenté comme une référence dans le
domaine le cours de la part de recherche
des restes de façon simplifiée j'aurais
le goût des gars c'est le chien de garde
la rigueur jusqu'en mars 2021 alain
croteau est l un des deux coordonnateurs
de recherche à la sûreté du québec ils
pouvaient alors compter sur ces
policiers spécialisés pour exécuter des
stratégies de recherche sur le terrain
mais en 2019 mario bouchard qui est
alors directeur général adjoint sous
martin prud'homme annonce la fermeture
des unités d'urgence permanente elle
était sur le point de fêter leurs 50 ans
c'est un démantèlement et c'est un
démantèlement sauvage en plus alain
croteau a toujours défendu auprès des
gestionnaires l'importance de maintenir
la qualité des services d'urgences à la
sûreté du québec au fil des ans il a été
témoin de nombreuses coupes et
restructurations mais jamais comme en
les quelques soixante dix policiers des
unités permanentes sont touchés par
cette fermeture
des chercheurs qui s'ils étaient entrés
knicks était formé de soi au tison
saupoudrez dans les laits poste
autoroutier à droite et à gauche et dans
différentes mrc
pourtant la sûreté du québec doit avoir
une unité d'urgence permanente pour
offrir des services spécialisés dans
toute la province et soutenir les autres
corps policiers au besoin c'est écrit
noir sur blanc dans la loi sur la police
quand qui n'ont coupé d'après moi il
savait me poseront faisait tout le monde
tout le monde sait ça pour de bon sens
affirmé ça se peut pas ils peuvent pas
fermer
il ne reste alors que les deux
coordonnateurs de recherche au service
d'urgence de la sûreté du québec la
nouvelle directive en cas de disparition
faire appel aux patrouilleurs
d'autoroute pour une étage où il ya d un
bloc opératoire on enlève tout le staff
et ont dit aux chirurgies 4 une
opération du poireau du personnel ses
étages alors moi on dit quant aux
réparations la charge par le personnel à
droite et à gauche dans les boîtes
sponheim ça fonctionne
et c'est pas tout le monde qui va y
aller si tu fais dénigrement food force
partout numérique un jeu 10
patrouilleurs de rouge nous lois qu'ils
votent repos ça drôle afin de vendre
c'est ce que lui reconnaît pas le
lendemain
d'un port ils sont pas formés ils se
produisent à marcher dans le mois on
voit ça des fois la télévision va faire
une chaîne humaine ce prof à des
recherches évidemment si tu diminue les
effectifs ben tu affecte aussi la
capacité de mobiliser des gens qui sont
en permanence à signer à faire ça c'est
encore faux conforme pas le choix c'est
incontournable
quelques mois après la fermeture des
unités d'urgence permanente la sûreté du
québec créer un nouveau module
d'intervention les exigences pour en
faire partie sont diminués les équipes
sont toujours basés à québec
saint-hubert et mascouche mais elles
sont réduites au minimum il y a moins de
formation - d'entraînement et -
d'exercices de simulation
ça fait un choc on a perdu on a perdu
l'essence même des services d'urgences à
ce moment là la crème de la crème s'est
dissipée drachme à bord ce qui est
inquiet pour leur carrière avec raison
ben ils n'ont plus d'autres fonctions
alors là le niveau de spécialisation
était à refaire
le 8 juillet 2020 la sûreté du québec
n'est pas prête pour une opération
d'envergure comme celle de
saint-apollinaire selon nos sources au
beau milieu de l'été est en pleine
restructuration de son service d'urgence
elle était privée de ses meilleurs
éléments ben c'est sûr que ça aurait
peut-être été différent s'il y avait eu
beaucoup s'est arrêté comme avant
et les chercheurs les plus proches de
saint-apollinaire ceux du module de
québec sont occupés ailleurs ils sont au
lac saint jean pour assurer la sécurité
du premier ministre françois legault qui
est passage dans la région c'est pour
cette raison qu'on appelle andré bernard
et ses deux collègues du module de
mascouche
invité à s'expliquer la sûreté du québec
a décliné nos demandes d'entrevue
préférant attendre de voir le reportage
avant de commenter
peu de temps avant la faire car partie
avant qu'on commence à parler de
démantèlement il y aurait eu à québec un
peloton en deux voies on aurait eu accès
un
probablement soir d'été ganchou 10 12
chercheurs
le soir même si on avait voulu
avant la restructuration si une équipe
avait été avec le premier ministre il y
aurait eu encore assez d'effectifs pour
une opération de recherches des
policiers auraient pu être déployé
beaucoup plus tôt à saint-apollinaire ce
qui aurait permis de trouver la première
trace de pas dès le lendemain matin de
l'accident
à mon avis à partir d'un millionnaire en
duel à la deuxième traces peut-être dans
des bus de pau midi mais tout au plus
oui oui
et l'eau avec la deuxième place ont un
sens de déplacement avec le sens de
déplacement on poursuit on aurait
certainement sauvé une journée on aurait
on aurait potentiellement sauver deux
jours
je me verrais mal vous dit aujourd'hui
qu'on est satisfaits alors que trois
personnes qui ont perdu la vie je
voulais du temps
on souhaitait tous et toutes retrouver
les fillettes à chanter
la coroner conclut que les petites sont
mortes environ 18 heures après
l'accident et qu'elle aurait pu être
retrouvé possiblement vivante elle met
en lumière une série de problèmes de
communication qui ont nui à l'efficacité
de l'enquète mais le rapport ne fait pas
état d'importantes lacunes de
l'opération de recherche identifiés dans
notre reportage le drame de cette
apollinaire et la démonstration d'un mal
beaucoup plus profond le rapport marque
eu tout un voile et du manque plein
cours de la monnaie selon nos sources ce
qui était sur place pour gérer la
recherche dans les premières heures de
l'opération ont fait de leur mieux mais
il manquait d'expérience pour s'imposer
auprès des officiers alain croteau
explique que dans de telles
circonstances l'équipe de recherche et
celle des enquêtes criminelles ont
tendance assez divisés de sorte qu'on se
retrouve souvent avec deux postes de
commandement je ne dirai jamais assez
s'apprend qu'imposera commandement
unifié avec un stratégie commune pour
que ça fonctionne et la stratégie
commune pour qu'elle soit possible ça
passe par le respect des spécialités
pour avoir lui même travaillé sur des
cas de disparition très médiatisée
impliquant les enquêtes criminelles
comme cédrika provencher à trois
rivières david fortin à saguenay
mélissa blais à louiseville l'ancien
policier affirme que ça peut être
difficile pour les experts en recherche
de se faire entendre dans le poste de
commandement steve field de dire aux
enquêtes faites confiance aux services
spécialiste des vrais pros des vrais
pros l'eau il ya pas si longtemps de
l'interaction des coupes et les services
spécialisés en recherche de rs on
devrait considérer ça comme les
démineurs à la sûreté du québec j'ai un
mec les enquêteurs avant et vod minable
et loisirs tu comprends le fil rouge
jamais c'est bien évidemment on va dit
aux gens aux dix mineurs solo je pense
que je te le bon peu tu regardes de soit
quelques mois avant le drame de
saint-apollinaire alain croteau avait
fait part de ses craintes à ses patrons
mais sans succès
et en plus on a le culot de dire ça va
être mieux elle fera pas de bon sens moi
j'ai entendu de mes patrons expliquer
aux gens de la sécurité civile qui qui
est inquiet entend parler de
démantèlement leur dire non ça va être
mieux après ça c'est honteux c'est stone
matri
le policier s'est même rendu jusqu'à la
ministre de la sécurité publique
geneviève guilbaud alors qu'il était
toujours en fonction
j'étais très nerveux parce que dans le
fond j'avais peur de représailles avec
un de ses collègues en octobre 2019 il
rencontre un membre du cabinet de la
ministre la ministre est juste à nous
seuls lui et puis est reparti fasse
cesser son travail et puis on est resté
avec la personne en question payant lui
a présenté les risques qu on entrevoyait
à la réduction des effectifs
alain croteau s'est sentie écoutée mais
il n'a pas eu de suite à cette rencontre
le cabinet de la ministre a décliné nos
demandes d'entrevue par courriel on
répond que comme de potentiels
poursuites sont encore envisagées nous
ne commenterons pas le dossier
au cours des derniers mois nous avons
rencontré plusieurs policiers toujours
actif à la sûreté du québec ils sont
frustrés et se sentent impuissants ces
policiers prennent le risque de nous
parler parce qu'ils sont encore témoin
de rater sur le terrain et parle d'un
enjeu de sécurité publique ils vont
jusqu'à dire qu'il ne voudrait pas que
leurs proches se perdent
selon eux si un autre événement comme
celui de cette apollinaire survient
demain matin des problèmes semblables
risque de se répéter même si certains
reconnaissent que tout n'était pas
parfait au sein des unités d'urgence ils
ont senti que le démantèlement était
improvisée et qu'il a complètement
désorganisé le service
c'est d'ailleurs un courriel anonyme
reçu l'été dernier qui nous a poussés à
nous lancer dans cette enquête le
message qui provient d'une personne
visiblement très bien informé témoigne
du malaise qui persiste à l'inter nantes
ou rend l'opération de saint-apollinaire
la personne parle de cafouillages et
affirme qu on a perdu de précieuses
heures de recherches
la source anonyme prétend que le
coordonnateur de recherche qui est en
devoir a refusé de s'occuper de
l'opération car il a trop de tâches et
que le deuxième était en vacances
j'avais notion de blanc qui planait un
peu sur les les coordonnateurs à
l'époque vous auriez dû rentrer si
c'était pas facile je me sentais
coupable de ne pas être entré
le coordonnateur en vacances dont il est
question dans le courriel si alain
croteau en juillet 2020 il travaille
toujours à la sûreté du québec et on
l'appelle pour l'opération de
saint-apollinaire
il est non seulement vacances mais aussi
à quelques mois de sa retraite
samoa et paralympiques à vous mais
gravelines de mémoire c'est la première
fois où malgré tout en vacances que je
refuse de rentrer au travail normalement
on m'appelait je rentrais tout de même
au travail
surtout que je me dis bien dans neuf
mois l'ond je serais même plus haut
alors vouloir faut apprendre à voler des
faux faut que je passe à autre chose
qu'un break les lip site était encore
vivante au début des recherches mais le
type que j'aurais pu accélérer les
choses
dès que j'aurai pu donner plus de
coordination mais l'on ait danger on est
dans l'après-coup maintenant conseiller
puis je regrette encore à ce jour de
peur de rater
[Musique]
au delà de l'opération policière le
drame de cette apollinaire ces trois
visages ceux de nora romy et martin
carpentier
trois morts tragiques mais aussi des
dizaines de vies brisées pour toujours
c'est très difficile pour les proches
qui préfère rester dans l'ombre mais la
grand mère maternelle des petites gaytan
nous a transmis une lettre dans laquelle
elle parle du vide et de la tristesse
qu'elle ressent et elle c'est à
souligner sa reconnaissance envers les
policiers
je ne veulent surtout pas condamner les
policiers qui sont allés sur le terrain
et les enquêteurs qui ont eu la pénible
tâche de nous annoncer le décès de nous
deux précise
j'espère que notre histoire fera au
moins réfléchir les hautes instances de
la sûreté du québec
quand c'est le temps de donner de la
formation sachez que je suis capable de
faire et ça me fait plaisir de la faire
retraité depuis un an alain croteau a
peut-être perdu la bataille de sa
carrière à la sûreté du québec met pas
sa passion maintenant que je suis
retraité j'essaie de redonner un groupe
qui m'ont inspiré pendant aussi
longtemps après avoir collaboré avec eux
pendant plusieurs années l'ancien
policier devenu lui-même bénévoles dans
un groupe de recherche et sauvetage ce
sont des civils forme et entrainé
équipés et surtout passionné il se rend
disponible pour aider les corps
policiers lors d'opérations de recherche
on reparle du responsable des opérations
mais depuis plusieurs mois le président
de leur association s'inquiète de ce
qu'il observe sur le terrain nous on est
preneur pour remplacer les policiers ne
pouvaient secondes et on nous dit qu'on
va nous déployer sané serment avant de
soudain pose comme le contrat de lâcher
sauvetage mois nous envoyer des à 17
heures à fouiller
puis aucun sans que nécessairement que
les policiers seront présents sont place
guy lapointe était impliqué comme
bénévole en recherche et sauvetage
depuis plus de 30 ans il est appelé à
travailler avec les différents corps
policiers de la province et il sent un
désengagement de la sûreté du québec
depuis un certain temps on peut pas
transférer le fardeau
sur le solo des dodos des bénévoles ces
questions de responsabilité civile ces
questions de la nation de la famille ses
relations avec les médias c'est pour le
rôle de nos bénévoles
recherche d'une opération policière
présentement la sorte et prendre des
budgets qui vont avec les opérations
mais de ne pas le service puis les
bénévoles qui voudraient donner un
service a autant pas les budgets puisque
le budget alloué à trop haute à la
sûreté du québec
on est prêts on à faire beaucoup parce
qu'on est super belle expertise
les bénévoles sont prêts à en faire plus
mais ils n'ont pas l'argent ni
l'équipement nécessaires annuellement
l'association reçoit seulement cinquante
mille dollars du gouvernement du québec
si c'est pas la sûreté du québec met ses
culottes qu'il fait à titre d'expert
bien qu'ils aient au moins la force de d
on est pas capable on veut peau on n'a
pas le budget peut importe mais on le
fera au pot si on veut pas donner une
équipe mais qu'on le donne aux bénévoles
structure et
ses équipes sont souvent sollicités des
opérations de recherche pour retrouver
des personnes disparues
il y en a plus qu'on pense mais elles ne
sont pas toutes médiatisée on parle de
la personne qui qui est prise à seront
chalet parce que le pont a cédé depuis
que t'es pas capable de revenir pillay
en intervention pour tvq et de ramener
on parle la personne qui s'est perdue
carrément on parle la personne alzheimer
on parle de la personne dépressive qu'on
a trouvé atteint tout cela il ya encore
énormément à chaque année on penser que
peut-être qu'avec le rapport de la
coroner ont pensé qu'elle a peut-être
guest de stabilité ou deux peut-être
juste de leur positionnement à part des
policiers dans la tup himo ce qu'on voit
ce qu'on constate le n'est pas fait pour
nous se réjouit elle dernièrement il ya
eu rapport de la coroner par rapport au
haut des c'est très malheureux des deux
soeurs carpentier qui ont été tués par
leur part martin carpentier en décembre
dernier la ministre de la sécurité
publique a présenté les grandes lignes
de sa réforme du système policier au
québec et il y avait eu des
recommandations par rapport justement
l'intervention à la disponibilité de
certaines informations en temps utile
geneviève guilbaud souhaite donner plus
de pouvoirs aux policiers pour obtenir
de l'information en cas de disparition
vous comprenez bien que chaque minute
compte dans ce genre de situation là ce
type de lois existent déjà dans
plusieurs provinces au canada il s'est
réclamé depuis longtemps au québec mais
rien dans le projet de loi sur les
opérations de recherche et sauvetage on
aurait pu déclencher
un lock médiatique plus tôt après la
publication du rapport de la coroner la
sûreté du québec a reconnu qu'elle
aurait pu déclencher une alerte plus tôt
elle assure avoir revu ses protocoles de
communication depuis et qu'elle
collabore avec le ministère de la
sécurité publique pour la création d'une
unité spécialisée en disparition pour le
reste de l'opération selon des documents
obtenus par la loi d'accès à
l'information
elle sûreté du québec estime avoir agi
promptement devant cet événement
j'ai comme l'impression qu'on va prendre
nous allons certainement vers loin mais
c'est des cas d'exception ces points de
collecte si je pense qu'on doit
sauter n'importe quoi andré bernard a
pris sa retraite plus tôt que prévu il a
quitté la sûreté du québec amer
même chose pour alain croteau mais tous
les deux espèrent que les choses
changent je vois tu la gueule plus
heureux au monde sait ça change parce
qu'un jour ce sera pas tâche sera
peut-être moins sera peut-être un proche
à ma famille car a besoin cette
expertise mais pas certain d'y croire
vraiment j'ose espérer
qu'on va prendre note
des événements de juillet 2020 la faire
car pas aussi pour
changer peut-être la façon de faire
évidemment c'est khayari des événements
comme ça qu'on se pose la question est
ce que on devrait repenser notre
réorganisation ben je suis convaincu que
la sûreté du québec il ya pensé souvent
on est revenu en arrière sur des
décisions de réorganisation des squats
comme ça des groupes comme ce
spécialiste
mais il s'est écoulé presque deux ans
depuis les événements et la direction de
la sûreté du québec qui n'envoie aucun
signal en ce sens sale interne c'est une
équipe qui coûte cher
mais je pense que
on peut promettre de prix sur la valeur
de votre père par exemple elle
m'apparaît disparaît demain où vous
attendent vous attendez certainement à
ce qu'on fasse des démarches avec raison
la grand mère maternelle guetta n'a
qu'une certitude la sûreté du québec
aurait pu en faire plus selon elle et
les cris
force est de constater que martin et les
filles étaient à quelques pas d'un
dénouement heureux cet homme était en
détresse et il vous a donné 18 heures
pour le retrouver
[Musique]